next we have affiliate marketing this is
a way for a company to sell its product
by having other people market it for a
commission if you join another company's
affiliate program usually wanted to pay
upfront only when people buy your
product or service through the other
company for example say we're on a
crafting blog and you see a link to
Amazon to buy craft related products
that is affiliate marketing in action if
you were to buy what Amazon was
advertising on the blog you the order of
the blog will get a percentage of the
sale price there are businesses that are
working with thousands of affiliates and
their lead generation relies on these
concepts other businesses are playing as
the affiliate and building their
business model as an affiliate for you
to begin with if it's not your core
business model you can start with a few
partners that can start as your
affiliates and you pay them per lead or
per conversion